hey everybody if you're like me you
finish the haunting of blime manor
insanely confused and needing a drink
once it watered down
i want an actual bloody drink but have
no fear
okay maybe some fear it is a horror
story it isn't it's a love story
we'll we'll we'll disregard that because
in this video we'll be going over the
ending's true meaning and what i thought
was the most
complicated aspect of the show how these
ghosts
actually work and let me tell you even
the actors didn't know what was going on
i would be honest if i said i'm not
still a little confused
yeah i don't know what the rules were it
a lot of sort of so take a dip in the
lake
make sure to like and subscribe because
this video is sure to be
perfectly splendid perfectly splendid
perfectly splendid perfectly splendid
okay enough of that well it is an ending
explained so why don't we start with the
very last shot of the entire season here
we have carla gugino's character
sleeping as
danny's hand rests on her shoulder we
learn in this final episode that
carla plays older jaime the gardener at
bly manor and danny clayton's love
interest
in episode 1 she's simply credited as
the storyteller because if they called
her older jaime it would give away one
of the biggest twists of the season now
you might notice older jaime doesn't
look like
younger jaime that's partly because it
would give away the twist
but also because the version of the
story we see is the one where
details have been changed so is it true
which part jamie perhaps to keep people
from ever visiting this mysterious
manner has altered just enough to keep
the main details of the story intact
but allow for its characters to remain
anonymous she even says that bly manor
isn't even the name of the actual home
i expect if you were to fly to england
you would find no such place by that
name
jaime's story bleeds into real life as
we see her attend the wedding of a
grown-up flora
who seems to have lost her british
accent if she ever had one in the first
place
after all remember that jaime has
changed some of the details
we do know she's older flora by the
credits we also know from owen that
miles and flora lost most of their
memories of bly and that's why flora
doesn't remember
jaime we also see older versions of
miles and owen and henry you may have
also noticed a manor by a lake in the
painting in the room where she tells the
story it's not blind manor or maybe it
is jaime has changed things in the story
it's up to us the viewer to decide
perhaps what makes this ending
hauntingly beautiful is jaime's longing
for dany who
one day just simply vanished but dany
and jaime knew this day was coming right
after leaving bly jaime makes plans with
dany for christmas
a few months away but dany is
apprehensive
she's apprehensive because she doesn't
know how long it will take for the
spirit of viola to take
over her the spirit she trapped within
her she calls this spirit
the beast of the jungle which is also
the title of the final episode
over the six or so years jaime and danny
spend together after bly
violas slowly creeps in starting to show
up in reflections like on the front of
their shop
or on a water pitcher it's when dany
wakes up one night her hand
almost wrapped around jaime's neck she
realizes she's lost control
it's only a matter of time before viola
and her rage takes over
so she does the most difficult thing she
can do to protect the person she
loves she leaves and she could not risk
the most important thing
her most important person not for one
more day
and it's important this line comes from
the storyteller or
jamie because she understands why dany
did what she did
she's come to accept it but at first she
didn't
when dany leaves jaime travels back to
bly in an attempt to reunite with her
even jumping into the lake and pleading
for her to take her just like dany took
the spirit of the lady of the lake
earlier in the episode but dany doesn't
take her
and danny wouldn't danny would never
in fact no one would ever be taken again
danny has decided to end this cycle of
pain
sacrificing being with her love to end
this vicious cycle
but to understand how all this began we
must go to episode 8 and the origin of
the lady of the lake in an episode
titled the romance of certain old
clothes
which happens to be a title of a henry
james short story the author who also
wrote the turn of the screw of which
this season is based
in fact this season is based off
multiple james stories including the
jolly corner
about a man haunted by his alter ego
just like henry is in episode 6 which
also has the same title the story
centers around vila who you may have
caught floor doing grave tracings of way
back in episode 4 a stubborn woman
inflicted by a disease simply known as
the lung viola watched as a love affair
bloomed between her
sister and husband and for six years she
treated her sister
dreadfully as her health waned viala's
disease ultimately caused her sister to
kill her
not out of mercy but she had just had
enough before her death viola makes her
husband promise not to open her chest
filled with jewels and dresses until
their daughter isabelle is of
age it's to be her inheritance but when
the family finds themselves in dire
financial straits perdita opens the
chest
only to be killed by vile as ghost a
woman whose soul never made it to the
afterlife after refusing to say her last
rights not much is known how this
transformation into a spirit happened
it's one of the show's main conceits it
asks you to buy into
all we know is that her strong will
stubbornness abandonment refusal of god
and betrayal by her loved ones combined
together to create what the show calls a
quote
gravity well trapping those who die in
its sphere whole towns want big gravity
well
it's easy to get stuck arthur viola's
husband stumbles upon the dead body of
perdita and ends up
throwing the cursed chest into the
bottom of the lake years later with the
hopes of reuniting with her daughter
isabel the lady of the lake goes through
this same routine
over and over again up to the master
bedroom and back to the lake again
killing anyone who gets in her way
that's why we see these mud tracks
throughout the home and why miles and
flora multiple times throughout the
season
try to stop dany from walking around the
house when they know the lady is on the
move take for example episode 1 where
they lock danny in the closet
this is a night the lady is out and
about flora knows this because of the
position of the doll the dollhouse
represents bly manor and the dolls are
all the humans and spirits in and around
it dany finds the doll representing the
lady of the lake underneath the dresser
and flora tells her not to move it
that's because the dresser represents
the lake whenever the lady is under the
dresser it's safe to move about the
night they locked danny in the closet
danny had almost tripped over it in the
middle of the room
meaning it was making its way to the
house in episode 2 we'll see the doll is
back under the dresser and miles and
flora are eager to play hide and seek
since they know the lady isn't anywhere
near the home
every time the lady goes back to sleep
she forgets everything that happened and
this cycle repeats for centuries as she
collects more souls this includes the
plague doctor when bly was used as a
quarantine home
you may have seen him lurking in the
background in the first few episodes
or the little boy who was mistakenly
taken by viola
as her daughter but as the storyteller
says time takes all things
even the soul and our memories as her
memories left her
so too her face that's what happens to
the spirits that bly over time their
faces
smooth over as if washed by time that's
why peter is adamant to find a way to
escape fly so quickly
because this is what happens to everyone
who doesn't
play and anyone who dies at blind manor
whether by the ladies icy grip or
otherwise
gets pulled into her gravity their souls
trapped on the grounds
this is what happened to hannah gross
who died after being pushed down the bly
well
she didn't die by the lady in the lake
but by miles who was controlled by peter
but we'll get to that in a bit
hannah has been a ghost the whole time
dany was at fly
that's why we never see her eat or leave
the grounds ghosts can't go beyond the
property line as that's the extent of
the lady's gravitational pull the thing
is
hannah doesn't know she's dead and this
is normal for new spirits
as miles tells her it takes a while for
them to realize they're dead in the
first place he equates it to the cartoon
character wiley coyote running off a
cliff
only falling after realizing the nature
of his predicament it's only until
hannah has shown her body lying at the
bottom of the well
does she know the truth and those cracks
that have been haunting her throughout
the season
are those of the stone inside the well
the beginning of the final episode sees
hannah and what peter calls
dream hopping think of it like a memory
infused dream these are largely
uncontrollable events as we'll see
almost all the ghosts thrust into
different memories they can't stop
like peter and his mother or miss jessal
and the night peter asked her to come
away with him to america
some are good memories and some are bad
peter is constantly dropped into a dream
where he has to confront his mother
who ignored signs that his father was
abusing him and who would later
blackmail him into stealing items from
the wind graves to pay her off he
relives this hell
over and over again one of the main
reasons he wants to get away from bly
and this vicious cycle
to add further pain he loses the ability
to touch and be with the love of his
life rebecca
jessel and so begins his quest to find a
way to be with rebecca forever
and leave bly once and for all after
revealing himself to rebecca as a ghost
the two attempt ways to leave spirits at
bly have the ability to possess the
living by touching them but only for a
short amount of time this explains miles
peeping in on dany
touching her hair seductively having a
smoke and most importantly throwing
hannah down the well
it wasn't miles who did this it was
peter controlling him peter possesses
rebecca and sees if that might allow him
to leave the grounds but
it doesn't work or so that's what we're
to believe i'll get to more of that in a
bit
those who are possessed have no
recollection of what happened during the
time they were controlled that's why we
have scenes like where flora wakes up in
the middle of the lawn having no idea
how she got there when someone is
possessed it's called being tucked away
because they are
tucked away in a memory laura has a lot
of these like when she meets the boy
with the unfinished face
or when she's given an acorn talisman
from her mother peter and rebecca want
to be together but he's dead and she's
alive the only way she can be with him
and touch him is if he possesses her and
she lives
tucked away in his memory but for peter
that means he's alone
she was safe tucked away in a memory of
them
where they could be together and he was
here alone so as possessed rebecca he
drowns her in the lake leaving her body
before she dies where she comes back as
a spirit technically they are equals now
like he promised but he never mentioned
killing her to do so but he tells her
there's a way out and that she'll quote
understand when she meets the others
peter's next plan is far more nefarious
essentially it's to possess the bodies
of miles and flora
tucking them away in what he calls their
forever home so they can live with the
memory of their parents forever this
would allow
peter and rebecca to grow up in the
bodies of these kids but more
importantly they'd be together and could
leave blind but how come peter couldn't
leave bly before as rebecca i actually
think he could have left but at the last
minute left her body knowing that
if he did leave as her they'd never
truly be together
it didn't work
like look at his reaction he's hiding
something plus
he previously said every time he's tried
to leave the property he gets
transported to where he died he died in
the manor yet he's not transported there
the moment i reached the edge of the
property
i'm right back here inside
right on the spot the biggest factor
however when it comes to controlling
someone as a ghost is consent and so
what we kind of came up with it's all to
do with consent
and so it's all to do with whether it's
an actual verbal consent or it's an
emotional consent
and that that's that would be the rules
giving yourself fully to someone else
allows you to enter them and control
them forever
you just need to decide that it's
forever
permanent that's where those lines it's
you it's me
it's us coming to play that verbal
consent these are the lines rebecca says
to peter before he takes control of her
and the same lines danny says to the
lady of the lake before she's about to
kill
flora how dany knew how to say these
lines is kind of glossed over in the
show
in that critical moment said what she
said
something she did not entirely
understand but something she felt
in her bones what danny did was open
herself up to the spirit
fully a far more inviting place than
trapped at the bottom of the lake in
that dreary bedroom and the moment that
happened all the other souls of the
spirits were released peter rebecca
hannah and all the rest
henry who was briefly killed by the lady
is brought back to life by cpr
he'll take over as the children's
guardian a man who once wouldn't even
set
foot at block he felt responsible for
the death of his brother and
sister-in-law in india a trip they went
on to rekindle their marriage after
henry had an affair with his brother's
wife
being at bly is a reminder of all that
hence why he never came but henry's
journey leads him to discover
some things are more important after all
flora is his daughter the final scene of
lie manor is almost a repeat of the
scene we saw in episode one older jaime
prepares a bath hoping to see the
reflection of her long-lost love she
even leaves the door slightly open in
the hopes she'll one day come to her the
song o willow whaley which plays at the
beginning of the show has the line
singing a willow whaley till my lover
returned to me and it also happens to be
a song from the 1961
jack clayton horror film the innocence
which is also an adaptation of the turn
of the screw
i guess we now know where dany's last
name came from dany's hand on jaime's
shoulder is open to interpretation
is she actually there with her or
perhaps this is
jamie dreaming her love comforting her a
symbol of her
always watching over her this video just
scratched the surface of blind manners
mysteries and i know there's a
ton i wasn't able to cover but if you
have an idea for another video or just
want to discuss what you thought of the
show
leave a comment below thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe i'm always coming out with
detailed breakdowns of your favorite
films and tv shows
for more bad takes follow me on twitter
and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much